reform of the European Union's fishing
policy tops the agenda at the next
council meeting in Brussels the reforms
aimed at bringing fish stocks back to
sustainable levels and providing
citizens with a safe predictable and
healthy food supply while rejuvenating
the fishing industry in February EU
ministers gave a mandate to the Irish
presidency to negotiate the reforms with
the European Parliament and the
Commission this time they'll debate
whether to adjust that mandate so the
talks can be completed agreement is
closed on most of the big fishing
changes but to finalize the package the
presidency needs new guidelines on some
core issues these include maximum
sustainable yields multi annual fishing
plans the obligation to land all
commercial catches and fishing capacity
management among other elements on
market regulation side the outstanding
issues concern mandatory information for
consumers also during the meeting the
United Kingdom wants to know whether the
Commission will impose trade sanctions
on Iceland and the Faroe Islands over
their quotas for fishing Northeast
Atlantic mackerel meanwhile European
Union farm ministers will be briefed on
the latest developments in negotiations
to reform the Common Agricultural Policy
the cat with the Parliament and
Commission the talks are focused on the
four main parts of the reform rules on
direct payments to farmers of common
organisation of the markets in
agricultural products rural development
support and the way the cap is financed
managed and monitored the presidency
aims to clinch of comprehensive
political Accord on the package with
Parliament at the end of June